[Music]
and shouldn't share news why I won't
submitted by Ross Ross I was like oh
I'll take it
you're like Krupps completely flip your
reaction more than 1000 people have been
charged by police and Denmark for
sharing a video of 15 year olds having
sex why would they do that
are they jacking off to it
do they know do they look 15 9 how do
they know they like having sex while
holding the ID is it like somebody was
caught [ __ ] in a high school and then
they kept passing around high school to
high school yeah they're like oh this is
some good fifteen-year-old sex like how
do you how do you know how why would you
want to watch that anyway it's just to
people like where does it go wait wait
why would she watch that my 15 year old
sex was not glamorous it was did you
guys [ __ ] to the Dawson's Creek song no
I eat my own way really [ __ ] a mile
like while it was playing lost my
virginity to a trial I lost my virginity
the Dawson's Creek theme for matsing
it's a match made in heaven that's a
great theme song homie I tried the whole
song this beautiful woman really is
really nice oh my god that's ridiculous
so this whole thing here is surrounding
these two video clips one of them is 50
seconds and you're gonna watch it no I'm
just did the other one is 9 seconds long
and they were shared through facebook
messenger apps right so police were able
to track down 1004 people that shared
these videos and so now they're talking
about like this is like a huge story out
there and Denmark by the way I don't
know if I'm and you did yeah for the
last few years now they've been having a
lot of awareness about the fact that if
you share any type of like revenge porn
or any type of child pornography it's
very illegal and there will be
repercussions so they've already been
like advertising this to everyone right
sharing awareness so then now that this
has happened a lot of people are saying
like they're not that innocent they know
that this is illegal and they should be
facing the consequences because some of
these people can face years in jail so
so
video they if they're clear about being
15 some people are saying like I hate
how was I gonna know they're 15 yeah
that's the very first defense yeah
saying that yeah I didn't know this was
against the law is my second defense yes
yeah always yeah and then when it was
first reported they were saying that it
appeared that the girl was being abused
in the video and apparently she was
penetrated with foreign objects the girl
later on came out to say that she did
consent to the sex but not to the abuse
or the recording of the video so then
that's why it's like another added layer
of like stay on this video it was it
like a hidden camera I'm not sure
exactly that's weird
apparently she somehow knew that someone
was recording but she said that she had
no idea that they would ever try to like
use this against her or even spread it
or send it to anyone else because then
later on it turned out that one of the
people that filmed the video was
blackmailing her and saying like hey you
need to send me nude photos of yourself
or else I'm gonna be sending this
everyone I know and that person is
clearly gonna be gonna go they gotta
build a whole new prison just to house
these thousand people that's a [ __ ] ton
of people it'll get them on RICO
conspiracy charges I love singing I
don't know so cool if you use Rico it's
a conspiracy charge they could use Rico
to take down whole entire organizations
from the top of the mob boss all the way
down to like the grunt drug dealer
so they trace it all the way to the top
so the whole organization gets taken
down except for just one person so it's
like that just translate that for you
dig in amman Rico yeah they get a Mon
Rico that's what a RICO charges that's
cool it's a charge the name of the tribe
it's a it's a conspiracy charge yet
where you can get the whole crew except
for just one person you can some time
yeah before that you had to only get one
person at a time because they were
independent but then now you could
create the whole web of the criminal
organization and take them all down for
that one person is writing them out and
that's the one person that I could tie
it tie it to a next one the next person
that would be part they all know they're
in the same organization this is like a
bunch of random people sharing on
Facebook it sounds like cuz a thousand
people like randomly sharing which is
why I'm they just Rico Facebook they
should Rico
to bring down everybody down everybody
you cut the head off one of them three
more pop up so we got to recall those
three more sets of 15 year old teenager
that's scary man I just feel like the
main people that did it should get in
trouble but if like if your person that
watches porn and you have like everybody
yeah and you see people and like I would
never share porn with somebody I don't
like that's weird it to somebody just
written like but like if you were
watching porn and like this is porn
sharing culture though weird is not a
part of it yeah as avid por connoisseur
I would never share my favorites we know
people that actually talk about their
subscription and they switch they pay
for and stuff they pay for it do they
know that yeah Wow so they do share
passwords and they exchange all that
[ __ ] Oh weird like I don't want to make
history of what I want shirt okay I
could see that if you were like into
anime porn or some weird fetish would be
into that your justed in normal sex like
a story but that's also us thinking of
Americans you don't I mean like maybe
other countries no and if I would I
could picture myself doing that in high
school where like if someone has access
and then they let me borrow their
password or whatever cuz like back then
we would pass around tapes that's true
okay all the people there so my point is
like if you're in that and you're
sharing your pulling with people um
huh I don't think if you saw a random
video and you're like oh this is good
like you and you passed it on I don't
think you would know that that they were
15 or like that you shouldn't share it
it's tricky it's the caption - is it
like hey had a nice jerk to this a lot
of girls like you what are you saying
that a lot of girls like act like they
don't like their being abused like
that's part of the cult like that the
roleplay yeah the roleplay is like no
don't you know so like I don't know the
video I haven't seen the video but maybe
it wasn't clear I just feel like each
person should be it should be an
individual thing not Rico yeah oh yeah
hate to burst your bubble I'm always
poor Rico recently I was watching
friends with KC and a dusting there Mary
they can do it now I got pay for friends
oh I tried to make Steve watch a Cuse
falling asleep during it it killed my
brain cells watching friends honestly I
feel brain cells leaving it's like I'm
it's like I'm in traffic and I just
smell gasoline I'm like that were Rachel
and Monica went to the bathroom to go
get a condom because they were gonna
have sex yep
I mean there's only one condom left they
were like trying to see like negotiate
like I'll do your laundry or whatever
yep and then after in the end they ought
to say like okay which one's gonna get
the condom but then after it was just
like go and have good sex and then they
both go into the rooms and then the both
of the guys come out they're looking at
each other and just I thought that was
weird it's like heart how are you gonna
have sex and like be turned on when like
your best friend
is like just right next door like I
found that really odd not only that big
so because my roommate was doing it and
we heard the noises and we started
laughing and then we started doing it
[Music]
well I'm not lusting to be in what
they're doing it's kind of like a
trigger to who they're doing so I would
stop is now that they're doing and you
can hear them you're like cool I don't
have to be quiet now cuz everyone else
is doing it but you're not listening to
them you're like completely inhibited
that's like then getting Korean barbecue
I don't like anybody we should get crazy
yeah it's like a suggestion yeah cuz
like for me I'm thinking about like then
I unintentionally start imagining what
they're doing there's a next level of
openness where people are willing to
just jack off in front of you to watch
so there's people that share porn right
so like I think for most of us we care
about our sexual privacy or whatever we
don't really like hey like watch this
porno I got my [ __ ] truck to this it
was so awesome
if it was don't let me know I sent
yeah I did to you but then there are
people that I like look how hot this is
let's jerk like whatever and we send
each other like truck material then
there's people that are like hey we
should just drunk together we do
whatever the other part I don't
understand because I'm not that open but
there are no there's a lot of people
that are on that side got that open
where they're down to jerk off my
friends used to have half circle jerks
like like for example people that are
down at bus the Train like when there's
like 10 guys one girl like I can't even
get hard if there's another dick in the
room but people but some people are very
open oh I get hard there's another dick
inner circle jerk is when you're looking
at each other and sir what's a half a
half circle is just a u-shape but you're
looking at the TV
my favorite [ __ ] important is when dude
yeah that's it's a half so I just made
jerking off together is the same thing
as a train pretty much like it's the
same people that are doubted but join in
the festivities but people would talk
about it in my junior high and like I'm
just like wow they would have jerk
parties like that's [ __ ] disgusting
my friends like they're so like I
consider them like family so it's like
imagining like oh you're right next door
is my parents having things you just
haven't lived life on the wild side no
I've been to parties where people are
drunk and then they're on the floor
just [ __ ] and I see a butt bouncing
up and down and I'm like oh [ __ ] I
didn't mean to see ya I've definitely
been in the same room as people I think
yeah I'm picturing all of us having sex
right now I'm picturing you in case
you're right now you guys are going
wrong you making another baby Thank You
styler
it's it's bearish cowgirl he's on top of
you picture a you and Jessica having
what i would argue some of the saddest
next I've ever seen looks like she's
trapped and you and me all we're going
at it baby
and how are you watching people what no
one picture you look at me like this
yeah he's having an out-of-body
experience having us it's a JK orgy
right yeah it's but we're all in the
same we're all in the same room and Rick
since when I'm the good time but but
we're [ __ ] our partners like
committed people yeah I think that
sounds just about right boring see
typical that is that show with you no no
you can't imagine your friends [ __ ]
at all
I guess I missed that stories I'm like
oh god no no you keeps trying to Incept
her bridge dude you should think about
that like doing ass appeals if you guys
are so hard I'm like oh really
[ __ ] my mine doesn't even go there I'm
not that horn just makes me like I'm not
attractive if you're not gonna think
about everything my only goes there if I
can't picture them [ __ ] like if I'm
like I can't see that guy and girl
[ __ ] oh that's the only time I'm
trying to imagine I can't see - [ __ ]
I kept it like oh we thought I could
picture you guys [ __ ] and I can
picture you and Casey [ __ ] I can
picture you just like so I'm like I'm
like cool I never think about it because
it's like okay my brain is like it
checks out it's fine
imagine sweet imagine sweet Casey in the
sweet face just over you like Casey just
oh okay Casey don't man yeah all I see
is Casey with this [ __ ] camera fully
clothed just [ __ ] getting an angle
like that's all I see and he's going
yeah yeah
I always picture [ __ ] Michael why why
do with this little picture and [ __ ]
with this pants I'm pulling his dick out
the [ __ ] people so he's still not
naked if you think Sir David and his
girlfriend but mostly I think cuz I
haven't seen his girlfriend in real life
so I got can't picture it I can't
picture David with with with this
girlfriend actually saying out loud like
not as a joke like Oh am i busting up I
can't actually say it's a hilarious of
it I can't get there
[Music]